good evening members and officers
welcome to the executive meeting of the
6th of december 2021
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
we have apologies from councillor simon
wooten
there are no other apologies everyone
else is present
gender item two non-members attending
there are none
gender item 3 minutes of the meeting
held on the 4th of november 2021
are these minutes agreed members agree
thank you
gender item 4 to receive declarations of
interest are there any declarations
please members
no thank you
agenda item five questions on notice
from councillors members there are none
agenda item 6 matters referred to the
executive and reports from other
committees
members there are none
moving on to agenda item 7 the mid-year
performance update 2021-22
naomi can i ask you to present this
please
thank you
thank you thank you chair um so yeah
this report sets out the council's
mid-year performance update for this
financial year
members will recall that we've committed
to provide half yearly updates to the
executive
to allow performance against the
council's business plan to be regularly
reviewed
the council's objective is to move
towards a more outcomes-based
performance performance framework which
um mirrors the corpora priorities which
are outlined in the business plan 2020
to 2023.
this is a move away from the historic
key performance indicator set which um
were used to be set nationally and
reported to central government and in
many cases this is no longer mandated
although um in a number of areas we do
still continue to collect that data
as the council is free to set its own
performance measures now
we are looking as i say to move towards
a more performance-based approach
however the key challenge is the
availability of data which can be
collected
in order to enable us to do effective
monitoring of that
particularly for those outcomes which
are less tangible in nature
so the report itself
has two appendices
um the first appendix um sets out a more
qualitative
approach in terms of
how we've met our key business plan
priorities
and this mirror is the approach that we
took last financial year um in our
year-end annual report
um the second appendix is the more
qualitative um set of key performance
indicators which supplements that
so i think the content itself should be
reasonably self-explanatory
um and we have tried to um obviously
give explanations of um where
performance has varied against our key
performance indicators
so
unless anyone has any particular
comments or questions on on the content
of those then
the report is just noting thank you
thank you naomi any questions members
no thank you
okay members so there is one
recommendation set out at paragraph 1.1
to note the contents of this report and
appendices 1 and two
is this no tip members
thank you
okay we move on to agenda item
eight
advice services contract 2022-2024
who is the moss we'll present this
report thank you louisa thank you chair
members this is a report recommending
that
we enter into a procurement process for
the retender of the advisory services
contract it's a two-year contract with
the option for a one-year extension the
value of the contract is 70 000 per year
and that's been the same cost for the
last actually six years for the last two
lots of terms of this contract the
current provider of the advisory
services contract is citizens of ice
south essex and their contract comes
naturally to the end at
the beginning of next year which is why
we're proposing the procurement starts
at that time
in the reports you can see that there's
some evidence to show why an advisory
services contract is so integral to
enhancing our services and aligns itself
with the prevention agenda generally and
some last six months outputs from
citizens of ice give you a flavor and
headline of just how much support they
give to key services within our
organization
and hopefully the rest of the report is
relatively self-explanatory but if there
are any questions then please do
ask
thank you louisa members any questions
councillor smith
thank you um as as you've said um
we've had this contract uh this price
for quite some time with uh citizens
advised we are out of curiosity than
anything but are there any other
players in the market who can provide
this service
um there are which is why we continue to
go out to uh procurement
there are some services although they
some not completely comparable
but we do know neighbouring authorities
have gone for other providers so it's
only fair and open that we should
continue to put this through a proper
procurement process accordingly but as i
say we are sometimes comparing and pairs
with apples but
there are other providers that provide
similar services but not all the
services that our current provider
offers
thank you louisa any other questions
members
no okay thank you
sorry councillor webb
thank you chair it's just more of a
comment really um just to looking at the
numbers here that they're excellent in
terms of meeting the needs of our local
residents
i think one of the things i
really appreciated when i had this
portfolio was the value of these
services out to our residents and it's
fantastic that as a district we're still
able to provide this level of service
because we need our residents need this
support and help at times so i'd like to
recommend this service to you thank you
thank you councillor webb
so members there are two recommendations
set out at paragraph 1.1
1.1 to agree that the advice services
contract should be retended
for a further two-year period with the
option for the council to extend the
contract for a further one-year period
it is proposed that the value of the
contract would continue to be seventy
thousand pounds per year
one point two to recommend that this
report is presented to full council on
the 7th of december 2021 to endorse the
proposals set out in sections below
members i will move those from the chair
do i have a secondary please
councillor williams thank you
members are you happy to vote for these
two recommendations on block
thank you
can those
members in favor please raise their
hands
that's carried
thank you members
okay we move on to agenda item nine
compulsory purchase of land at michelin
farm rayleigh
councillor ian ward
portfolio holder for strategic planning
will introduce this report thank you
council award
thank you madam chairman
um
this paper
is coming to executive to solve a
long-term issue
it's basically
um to look at initial surveys and
services
initial investigations and survey work
to be undertaken in regards to
compulsory purchase
of michelin's farm
we are asking to have a drawdown
of 25 000 to enable officers to prepare
a business case
for compulsory purchase
i would like it noted on item 1.3 just a
change
if i can put in there
to delegate responsibility to the
assistant director
place and environment
assistant director of legal and
democratic
and also consultation of the portfolio
holder for strategic planning
that can be noted within that particular
area thank you
the supporting evidence is within this
document
it is very comprehensive in the route in
which we are about to look at this is
exploratory at this moment
just to see where we need to go
so i recommend and
i recommend this to the executive thank
you
thank you council aboard
councillor smith
could i just ask the council award if he
prepared to
accept one small
amendment to 1.2
to approve a drawdown of reserves of up
to
25 000.
oh
council award
yes madam chairman i'm quite happy to
accept that amendment
thank you council award okay council
smith
thank you
any other questions
members thank you
so members there are three
recommendations set out in paragraph 1.1
1.1 that the executive agrees to bring
forward report to consider using the
council's compulsory purchase
powers to acquire land at the michelin
farm rally
once initial investigations and survey
works have been undertaken
1.2
to approve a drawdown from reserves of
up to twenty five thousand pounds to
enable officers to prepare a business
case the compulsory purchase of land at
michelin farm rally
one point three to delegate
responsibility
responsibility
to the assistant director place and
environment and assistant director legal
and democratic
in consultation with the portfolio
holder for strategic planning
to negotiate the potential voluntary
purchase of the land
in parallel to the compulsory purchase
order
process
and report this back to the executive
for consideration
members i will move those from the chair
do i have a second to please
counsel fd
members are you happy to vote vote for
the three recommendations on block
thank you can those members in favor
please raise their hands
thank you members that's carried
okay moving on to item 10
council program management office
and angela hutchins will
present this report thank you angela
thank you chairman um in relation to
this report members you'll recognize
this as being the quarterly report of
the council's program management office
in relation to the key programs which
the council is
undertaking
the report itself is self-explanatory
but we are available for questions
should you have any
members should note that if the
partnership with brentwood borough
council is approved in the new year the
transformation programme required to
implement the ambitions of that
partnership will effectively become the
program management office and
effectively subsume this report going
forward so this is
at this stage potentially the last
report in this format thank you
thank you very much members any
questions
no okay thank you
remember the members there is one
recommendation set out in paragraph 1.1
and that's to note updates on the
council's three projects the connect
programme and the asset delivery program
both gold projects
and the beagle event project a silver
project
is this noted members
all noted
members that concludes the business for
this evening and i close the meeting at
1943. thank you all very much
okay